Delos is gonna kick us off with a
question I think a great question
so my screens off of them feeding my son
and so I really have I think it's really
interesting how they have Chinese
medicine as one of the I guess drugs
that are given can you give an example
of what that would so I'm not exactly
sure what the exact treatment was but
the traditional Chinese medicine are
just kind of kind of things that in
their culture they they consider to be
medicinal and that patients are
sometimes given within within Chinese
hospitals so I'm not exactly sure like
what they are specifically but that's
just something that they consider to be
a medicinal yeah I think that's really
interesting how like cultural thanks
play a role in like medicines that
people take definitely yeah
yeah I've also heard that there's a lot
of sort of culturally related diet but
diabetes treatments you know something's
related to like turmeric and cinnamon
and and things like that depending on
which culture you're coming from um
speaking of region I'm wondering do you
do we know if the rate of diabetes in
the areas where the study was performed
is at a different rate or I guess
absolute number even then you know what
we are seeing in the United States
because that is is like a huge disease
here is it as big and in China sorry did
you say diabetes or copa90
diabetes diabetes diabetes I think is
more prevalent in the United States than
in China yeah just rising yeah when
you're just for a population yeah and
I wonder do you think that with you know
if we know we're going into speculation
mode with the ideas around like so we
have higher rates of diabetes here in
the United States and you know we're not
controlling kovat I mean do you think
that like the the extensive death rate
that we're seeing here compared to other
places is is in part because of some of
these comorbidities or do you think it's
more related to like mismanagement of
like you know social distancing or
testing or things like that or even
helping yeah yeah yeah absolutely I
think it's definitely a combination of
all those factors but I definitely think
since we do have like a much greater
incidence of type 2 diabetes
specifically in the United States I do
think the reason why we're seeing so
many deaths and severe outcomes in the
United States is much higher again
because we we have these communities of
color which suffer from type 2 diabetes
at much higher rates than many people in
the world so that definitely could be a
major factor and why we're seeing so
many deaths and severe outcomes the
United States yeah well thanks all right
so we have a question from the audience
so the question is have these results
informed early treatment of people with
type 2 diabetes at covent 19 are there
trying to get blood glucose under
control why shooting for club in
nineteen i'm so sorry did you work that
question yes I think they're wondering
if the results of the paper are
informing on any early treatments for
people with type 2 diabetes and may
become infected with clove in nineteen
that's the first part and the next part
like are they trying different things
like keeping your blood glucose under
control while treat for treating for
Koba 19 based on the results of the
paper
so so you address the early treatments
question so from from these results I
mean they are advocating for basically
just in general better control of your
like blood glucose if you're diabetic
just because Koba 19 is spreading
through there also quickly sorry could
you repeat the second question are there
trying to get the blood glucose under
control when people with type 2 diabetes
get hospitalized would Koba 19 I don't
know man or right right right yeah so
yeah one major yeah they did they did
advocate for for that but again a really
big limitation of the study was that it
was retrospective so they couldn't
actually follow if making their blood
glucose better would basically make
their Koba condition better over time so
that's why I'm doing a kind of a
prospective study would really improve
these results but they do still say that
they believe that for a patient that's
hospitalized for kovat and that has type
2 diabetes one thing that definitely
could help would be to manage their
blood glucose in real-time cool yeah
that's probably pretty critical um so
what about you know diabetes has its own
set of comorbidities right you have lots
of heart disease issues related to the
diabetic kind of milieu as they say so
how you know were there any kind of
indication in terms of like the presence
of cardiovascular disease or specific
demographics like age or other types of
medications that they're taking that may
be not related to diabetes was there any
indication that patients were you know I
guess
was there any summary of like patient
history and how those factors could have
also impacted outcomes or did the
we're not going to that so the paper did
go into it but for for the really big
results where the graph that showed the
survival rates they actually adjusted
for other comorbidities like heart
disease like liver disease so they kind
of tried to only focus on diabetes
although they did mention that those
kinds of conditions and comorbidities
typically come with type 2 diabetes and
are present in people who who do have
type 2 diabetes and they do say that
these are these factors that we can
impact morbidity but that wasn't that
wasn't like the focus up there cool
thanks and that was from Peggy from
Facebook so thank you for asking that
question and the first question I asked
are you aware of any measures that China
has implemented in response to this
paper in ways that they can promote or
better manage type-2 diabetes in our
population so I I'm not actually aware
and this paper is pretty recent but I
can imagine that since they they use
like all the patients that have koban 19
and the sub-province that they
definitely are probably using the
results from this paper to currently
treat individuals who have go to 19 and
tattooed IDs although I'm not exactly
sure
well so we have a question from Susan
who's one of our rock edu moms so hi
Susan thank you for your question why
was the group limited to ages between 18
and 75 so the reason they limited the
cohorts in in the dimension of age
basically is because so first for
individuals who are above the age of 75
these individuals typically have a bunch
of other kind of conditions which could
actually be confounding factors for this
study so those individuals were
eliminated and then people who were
under the age of 18 could also have a
lot of these factors
but also I would imagine that there
there must be some law for individuals
who are under 18 to not be consenting
yeah I wonder like we have in the United
States the age of 18 as like the sort of
barrier between child and adult that you
know is that a universal age across the
world in some places I think it's 16
okay interesting yeah yeah I wonder what
it is in China hmm I'm ignorant when it
comes to that stuff so I apologize yeah
I actually I'm not sure either but I
think the main reason is because II they
just couldn't like represent confounding
factors in the analysis the data yeah
good point another question do you think
or is there a difference in the lungs of
people with type II diabetes I think
this is pointing at the fact that Koba
19 seem to inflict inflict on lung cells
more than other cells in the body
yeah so they actually did talk a little
bit about this in a paper saying that
individuals who have really advanced
type 2 diabetes particularly individuals
who have the fully controlled blood
glucose often have damage in their
vascular systems as well as in their
kind of related lung system so the paper
does mention that they think that's
actually where the comorbidity for the
respiratory illness comes from this the
degradation of kind of like vascular as
well as respiratory systems as a result
of diabetes so we have a question from
Chloe who was d4p
fellow one three sessions of the go if
you're including this one so welcome
back Chloe thank you for joining the
question is did all type 2 diabetic
patients receive the same standard care
for copa90
and if not did the survival analysis
showing differences between the well and
controlled patients account for that
so the treatment was very uniform for
just Koba 19 patients in general but the
differences came when the patients had
severe outcomes so if for example they
had be like ARDS syndrome which was the
acute respiratory distress syndrome then
they of course had to have different
treatments than then did other patients
and they what they did was they didn't
they didn't compare directly patients
who basically didn't have like the same
treatments so they kind of like
delineated it in that way to kind of
remove that as a compounding factor of
course you can't remove all all factors
that confound the analysis but I think
they tried their best in that regard and
question for McKenzie so can you talk
more about why poor BG blood glucose
control exasperates covin 19 from
physiology mhm
physiology perspective yeah so there
really a plethora of reasons so when you
have really poorly controlled what blue
coasts
it means that you're either not getting
enough insulin or your your condition is
maybe really advanced so in this case a
few things can be happening so as a
result of like all the all the glucose
in your blood again it can cause a lot
of damage to your vasculature it can
cause they have a damage to your nerves
it can cause a bunch of damage to
multiple organs and then of course since
the cells are getting at glucose they
can be hugely chemical cascade where a
bunch of issues can occur just just
because a lot a lot of like processes
that typically will be occurring won't
be occurring so then as a result of all
this a bunch of a bunch of different
diseases can manifest actually from type
2 diabetes like I mentioned like liver
disease kidney disease
like that and then what happens then is
kind of like a bunch of things happen
but then your immune system can also
really become compromised and we know
that from that you can have really
severe outcomes from Koba 19
yeah and in general the answer is
there's a lot of reasons but I think the
main reason is just because your systems
basically just start failing and then
your immune system is compromised and
then you're just more susceptible to
severe outcomes creeping along those
lines you think medication might have
anything to do with that like so people
with type 2 diabetes are taking
medications at mind-altering other
aspects and body yeah I definitely think
that is a factor for sure however I'm
not I'm not really exactly sure about
the specifics although this study did
show that even though the quality
control blood glucose group were were
given more medications they did survive
less than than the well control block
with no sputum
yeah I think we're gonna end with one
last question from Aditi thank you for
joining us once again so I'm happy to
have you back with us I think you might
have the frequent flyer card for d4p at
this point in time I think one day maybe
we'll get you a free coffee out of it
for ice cream so her question is since
the study and others concerning Kovac 19
have been performed in China how are the
results or implications being
interpreted in other nations and aren't
other nations taking actions to
specifically address populations with
type 2 diabetes
yeah so since this the study was
performed in China obviously there are
certain cultural factors and certain
community factors which could definitely
affect the results but in general I
think since the study was so rigorous
and it was performed on such a humongous
cohort again it was like 7,000 total
patients I think it's being interpreted
pretty generally all over the world
although again as I mentioned certain
communities like he needs a color which
disproportionately are affected by both
type 2 diabetes as well as kovat may
have like unique factors which affect
their comorbidities so a certain aspect
of this study may not apply to those
communities but I do I do believe that
similar similar studies like these are
being performed in the United States in
these in these particular communities
and all around the world I think it's
really interesting when you mentioned
it's not really having type 2 diabetes
but whether or not it's being well
managed some of the issue here where
some of those communities is that you
know access to health care is a big
thing so getting the medication to
control can definitely impact that yeah
or like it the price of insulin here in
America it's just out of control you
know is so all of these things I'm sure
this is gonna be a very messy data set
coming out of the United States I think
when we look at this type of data for us
yeah that's another reason why the
American system needs an overhaul right
right yeah and I think I think the data
in the United States is gonna be so so
high dimensional because there's just so
many factors social like economic
biological obviously that kind of play
into this issue so I think it's gonna
take a lot of a lot of really good
analysis to kind of like figure out what
the what the exact causes really are
yeah I think makes the data really messy
and I'm thinking about a time I went to
an international conference and a lot of
they're like researchers still even
XR mentioned socioeconomic status cuz
that's not an issue in their country
yeah it's so it's really highlights I
think the system in the United States
especially but I actually don't think so
soon recognized I think socio economics
is an issue in every single country it's
that there are more there are cultures
that are more comfortable ignoring it
than others and I think United States
will be in Ostend falls into that you
know we're very uncomfortable talking
about it you know this is everybody
likes to be in their little bubble
privilege and you know we really need to
start dismantling that yeah yeah and I
think you know Leeanne mentions we all
agree that reducing type 2 diabetes is a
priority of course it's a priority for
everybody this is definitely one of the
big up this is a pandemic just in a
different way you know